drugs guns Paris and Travolta looking
like Bill Goldberg cool let's find out
[Music]
from Paris with love now I was on the
fence about this movie I wanted to see
if it was even gonna be like the Bourne
extreme or the transporter light and it
was more like that second one now this
movie had one great thing about it and
that's John Travolta imagine if Jack
Bauer had a kid with samuel l.jackson
that would be Travolta's character in
this movie and that is pretty much the
best description i can give about you're
both in this movie his character just
makes the movie he's extreme unorthodox
and very badass as for Jonathan Rhys
Meyers he's okay he's an average guy
who's being given his big shot by
teaming up with John Travolta in this
movie but it's not like he stands out
he's likable enough but anyone could
have played his role and would have been
the same thing unlike Travolta where you
walk out of the movie theater totally
convinced that this role was made for
him
oh I mean him or Jack Bauer and Samuel
Jackson's love child
now the first half of this movie feels a
bit disjointed but has some sweet-ass
shootout sequences we're talking
hard-boiled style and all right
maybe not that intense but they're cool
then at a point the plot focuses and
finds its niche but then you realize
that plots been done a lot but there's a
definite moment in the movie where you
like this movie just got a whole lot
better the only thing it takes about 45
minutes to reach that point yeah 45
minutes of a 90-minute movie yeah the
movie kind of seemed like a more extreme
version of rush hour only with no
kung-fu but awesome shootouts and you
can understand what the people are
saying in this movie and hopefully
Travolta doesn't do a movie like The Spy
Next Door mmm yeah close enough so I'll
break it down for you like this if you
want to see some sweet shootouts and
don't mind a plot that's about as
focused as kindergarteners huffing glue
watch the first half if you want to see
it not great yet enjoyable enough but
already been done a hundred times before
Secret Service type movie then watch the
last half and if one character is enough
to make a whole movie for you and you
want to see John Travolta in a badass
sarcastic be it over the top yet
enjoyable roll then watch the whole
thing and if you're looking for a sweet
fresh focused and awesome take on spies
and national security yeah watch none of
it but we get the Jack Bauer Power Hour
every Monday night not really saying
that from Paris with love is like 24 and
just saying 24 is awesome is it me or
more and more does television do things
a lot better than movies nowadays who
thought so if you've seen from Paris
with love
comment I'm interested to hear your
thoughts do you agree with me do you
disagree you kind of agree but not fully
agree but you agree that we can agree to
disagree
comment I love the feedback and if you
like what you've seen here and you were
thinking just now yeah I wonder what his
other reviews are like then click on the
link in the sidebar to see more or
subscribe if you're feeling bold or as
always you can just click here